this is a production of cornell
university
so
welcome everyone thank you for joining
the
final
hemp webinar series
i
don't want to speak for you all but i've
had an absolute blast
with this seminar series and
i've learned so many different things
and i want to reiterate my gratitude
towards our wonderful speakers
um george tony gemma and kim for
handling so many logistics associated
with this work our interpreters etc
and last but not least i want to thank
y'all for showing up every week
i hope this has provided some real value
all of these
are available on youtube on the cornell
sips cornell s-i-p-s
uh channel and please view them review
them share them
so
today
um i wanted to just
briefly reiterate our work at cornell in
the usda so we're trying to build the
world's largest seed library of
genetically and geographically diverse
hemp
genetic resources so this can be seeds
clones etc our goal is to store them
safely
long term
characterize them collect data all kinds
of data about them
and then share those seeds and the data
with
many different
stakeholders and collaborators
so
sometimes people will be trying to breed
new varieties of hemp that are adapted
to different regions or studying the
genetic mechanism that controls fiber
quality in hemp those are two of very
two potential applications that our work
will enable
so
let me stop talking about us and let's
get on to
the real topic today
so i'm thrilled to introduce to you dr
tyler mark
so dr mark's research group is
developing a local regional national and
internationally known research program
that is grounded
in an interdisciplinary approach
this approach has yielded 31 research
publications
secured over 24 million dollars in
extramural funding
communicates that research
back to key stakeholders
and is continually building new
collaborations
within and outside of the university of
kentucky
in 2014 he was
recognized as a seafair aaa
early career professional leadership
award winner
and in 2016 he co-authored the golden
quill award for the most outstanding
article published in the journal
of american society of farm managers and
rural appraisers
in 2018
one of his master's advisees was awarded
the saea outstanding master's thesis
award
his current hemp research efforts
include hemp market metrics
national survey of hemp production costs
evaluation of hemp crop insurance
and best management practice for hemp
contracts alternative pricing method for
hemp products
consumer demand for hemp products
life cycle analysis
of hemp grain for aquaculture production
and evaluation of hemp grain for beef
production
and estimating the economic impact of
hemp
production so he's clearly been very
busy and he's extremely knowledgeable
i'd like to make two points before he
starts
the questions always fill up really fast
so if you want him to answer your
questions start putting your answers in
the q a not the chat the q a
as soon as you have them
and we'll organize them and try to get
to them in a timely manner
secondly i love seeing where all y'all
are from it's so so exciting to see
people from almost every continent we
haven't had an antarctica
watcher yet but everywhere else
so without further ado uh i bring you
tyler mark
excellent thanks zach for the
opportunity to to be here this afternoon
and
um let me get my screen shared here and
we will get rolling because we're going
to cover
um a whole lot of ground uh this
afternoon as um
you can imagine and as zach talked a
little bit about the group i work with
uh has been extremely busy uh over the
past several years and since i've been
working in this in 2014 since 2014. so
we're going to talk about the economics
of hemp production
but before i get started you know all
this work would not be possible without
all my collaborators from across the
country and across
you know even some international across
governmental organizations as well and
i've thrown a
i think almost all of them up here if
somebody's on here and i missed you i
apologize uh because uh there are a lot
of different people i work with on a lot
of different projects we're going to
talk about a lot of those different
projects today and some of the results
that are really starting to come from
from a wide range of these projects so
just to kind of give you a little bit of
a feel for where we're going today we're
going to touch on policy we're going to
touch on production we're going to touch
on consumption and then we're gonna do
maybe look into the crystal ball a
little bit and try and look forward uh
as to what's coming and you know i kind
of browse through the
the participant list and there's a
number of you that i've spoken to before
and if i haven't ever spoken to you and
you have questions uh we can't get to
them today feel free to reach out uh and
i'm more than happy to to try and
address those questions uh the best i
can or at least point you in the right
direction so
all right so let's get started
so on on the hip policy front this is a
paper and and some pieces that we're
working on with the ars or not ars ams
i'll try and get all my acronyms right
today but
unfortunately that'll probably uh miss a
little bit but this is a usda-funded
project
we've been really looking at uh hemp
policy and as it kind of spans across uh
time so we have the 2014 farm bill and
all by the you know we have the 2014
farm bill that just finally sunseted um
on january 1st 2022 this year but in the
meantime we have the 2018 farm bill
along with the final rule and the
interim final rule they were all
published so we had all these different
moving components in this so that's
really caused a lot of confusion
in the policy space so we've been trying
to go back uh and look at these hemp
plans and what they actually say in them
what they mean
what type of verbiage is being used in
them are they consistent across time and
you know we would have thought that as
we move from 14 to the 18 farm bill that
we would have gotten some more
consistency and we did get a little bit
more consistency but we still got a real
long way to go to to have a an efficient
set of regulations for this industry so
i kind of have down here at the bottom
bottom right you know the 23 24
farm bill and what are we going to do
with that and what is that going to look
like so a lot of my group and a lot of
individuals within my group are starting
to think about what are the types of
policies what do we need to be
communicating to
regulators legislators uh what what
types of issues are we seeing
on this front from a hemp standpoint
that we can help fill in some of those
gaps with
so that's really something that's been
on the forefront here lately
to think about and we can talk about
those maybe in the questions
later on
but
you know we as we were looking at these
we thought they might become more
consistent however um what we really
found and to some degree is expected
these are really really driven at
defining the difference between hemp and
marijuana
so which was
needed but
at the same time also still causes a lot
of confusion because if you start to
look at a lot of the plans and you start
to you know we looked at uh 67 different
plans so now you're going to tell me
well they can't be 67 different plans
because there's not 67 states well
there's not 67 states but there are 50
states plus uh um
tribal governments so when you start to
throw in each one of those individual
tribal governments you start to really
expand that number you know and so hemp
isn't even mentioned in all the plans
it's
in terms of the way it's defined then
you could get examples like licensee and
registrant so they mean the same thing
but they're in two different plans uh
you can get lot lot means one thing and
one plan and lot means a different thing
in another plan if you start to read uh
the
the different plans closely so we've
still got a lot of confusion and this
paper um should be coming out hopefully
pretty soon we're in the process of
getting revised and resubmits done on it
but i think this will help clear up uh
or at least point to uh some of the
additional issues that we need to really
think about for the 2014 uh sorry the
2023 2024 farm bill
depend upon when it actually comes out
so this has been one area
in terms of policy we've been looking at
and i'll talk about some more a little
bit later but i'm going to dive now into
kind of where i got started at in this
space and this is on the production side
so one of the pieces that i've been
working on with some colleagues in
colorado state is trying to look at the
differentiation of what happened to
different states as they came into
production so when i start to think
about those states that came in in that
2014 time period the kentuckys the
colorado's
you know
vermont and a few other states in there
so what happened to them how did they
come out and peak and so this graphic
right here you see that they kind of
peaked at around 50 000 acres in 2019 we
all know 2019 was kind of the peak of
this industry uh for for the time being
i think we'll see many more acres in
this over time but
where we currently stand so they they
peaked around here and they've been
following pretty quick you know that
group that came in in 2016 they peaked
even higher you know as interest was
really ramping up to that 24 2019 uh
growing season those states that came in
later have been kind of a little more
flat
but we've been trying to really figure
out what has driven some of the
adoption and disadoption in these states
when we start to think about
uh contr expansion and contraction of
the hemp industry uh within these states
so this is a lot of interesting work
that that also will be coming out pretty
soon as well now keep in mind we have
not differentiated especially in these
two graphics
between
floral green and fiber so they're all
kind of lumped together right now and
that's something else we're trying to
parse out however you know we don't have
a whole lot of grain and fiber acres
in the country or as many acres in the
country
so you know starting to think about um
this and kind of where we're at in the
state of kentucky and kind of the state
of the industry
you know when we start to think about
the top 10 hemp states montana colorado
kentucky down here
you know when we look at
usda's
national agricultural statistics service
survey that just came out in february
they said we had about 54 000 planted
acres about 33 000 harvested acres and
about 824 million dollars
in uh value now you can start to think
about is that really an accurate number
is that inaccurate is that is that high
or low
what i would tell you is is that yes
there are some differences between what
you see in the planet acres for the mass
survey versus what you see on fsa
uh and other reporting services but
i i would just say hold on because we're
we're gonna get better at this uh now in
2022 we have to report to fsa all the
hemp acres that are produced so that's
going to help clean this up clean this
data up but this was a nice first run
at um
at these types of
figures and stuff from a national
standpoint
and i think we're going to have a couple
other
surveys come out i know specifically
myself we we have between myself and
colorado state
and ams we have a national production
cost survey that we're in the process of
trying to get out we were hoping to
already have it out however
the wheels of government sometimes move
a little slow so we're still trying to
get that through omb
but hopefully we'll get that out in 2022
and we'll have another really in-depth
uh census look at
what all is going on in the in the u.s
hemp industry and i think that'll
provide us some really nice
baseline numbers for as we continue to
expand this industry
over time as now we've come from the
2019 time period now the industry gets a
chance to reset
uh and launch again
probably as we start to see more grain
and fiber acres come into play
but i also want to take a moment and
step back here and put this industry in
perspective when we start to think about
other crops uh in the country so
you know we're talking about 54 000
acres that puts us at a really really
small i mean there's less acres of hemp
than there are cucumbers
so
keep in mind where that plays at on the
national landscape you know when we
start to think about how this plays in
the farm bill and where the work we're
going to have to do to get recognized
as a larger crop and move out of kind of
this specialty crop place
now that the floral side may stay in the
specialty crop space but i think grain
and fiber are going to move out into a
more commercial space
and can be with those traditional corn
and bean
those types of commodities uh in that
space but keep in mind we're pretty
small fish in a big pond right now
so that's that's really where we're at
when i start to think about that
so i'm gonna bring in and talk compare
and contrast a little bit here
some floral pricing stuff now this is
from the nas survey one thing that we
really learned from the nasa survey is
we we didn't do a very good job of
asking the question so if you look at
this
from an outdoor perspective
you see the price is down
less than 100 a pound
and and this is still even higher so
really what we picked up here is the
smokable price
which is an industry that i i don't even
think with the nas survey we were really
trying to pick up
however it's not shocking that we picked
that up right because if you start to
think and you go forward in this graphic
and you look at
the biomass pricing biomass price has
dropped precipitously
since that 2019 july 2019 time frame you
know we're down here less than you know
in a lot of states less than 20 cents uh
30 cents per point so producers saw that
this wasn't a profitable profitable game
anymore to to be in this space so what
did they do they switched to the
smokable space so they picked up a lot
of the smokeable space so they could
survive um you could also throw in delta
eight uh played a role in that we'll see
what happens from a policy regulatory
standpoint of delta 8 going forward as
to if that continues to be a viable
option
for producers
moving forward
after the 23-24 farm bills so this is
something that that's really happened in
the industry
but here's that smokable price if you
want to look at the smokable price you
know this is this is really more
indicative of what nas picked up
in their survey which i think is
interesting uh
and and also helps uh us to think about
this next national survey of making sure
that we differentiate between uh floral
or biomass price and the smokable price
in the industry so that we're putting
comparing apples and apples
really with our production cost surveys
but
smokable price has been kind of holding
on i am using panax exchange
as a source of pricing right now for for
some of this uh most of you probably
know there's no open source uh to do
that with so
that's something to to think about as
well
i also brought this down and put this in
a floral pricing because i think it's
also really interesting to look at this
across states so the midpoint you'll see
oregon kind of dropped out here oregon's
got a really low price they've had some
really big issues out there that they've
been trying to deal with
but if you look at colorado kentucky
uh northeast great plains they're all
kind of pretty similar right here right
around this 20
20 27 28 cents per point uh tight period
for a midpoint the high side the high
side is probably the newer material this
low side will be all the old materials
so remember we had that surplus and
material on the market from 2019 and
2020 so we're still trying to get that
off the market hopefully we've worked
through most of that
when i was out at the noco
for for that meeting
they talked about moving supplies of
biomass
storage from about 2 million last year
down to about 50 million this year
hopefully
well my bigger question on the 50
million pounds is still left in surplus
is what type of um is that in a crude is
that in floor material still you know
how has that been stored in is it
actually still valuable
there are some companies out there that
are trying to buy up as much as that as
possible
because you're starting to see that that
amount left that 50 million pounds is
not a whole lot so
left on the market so companies are
trying to buy that up before prices
start to i think trend back up in 2022
and 2023 as we see some areas in the
country
where um
where biomass supplies is in pretty
short supply um
on that side of the coin so that that's
a bright spot that i'm kind of seeing as
well
but i wanted to pull this back you know
just the the economic basics of this so
uh cbd is it's really a struggle right
now when you start to look at this and
you may or may not agree with the
pricing components and the and the uh
percentage cbd percentage i put in here
and i'll talk about that in a second
because you'll see the 39 cents per
point you know it's kind of on the upper
end or the high end of what we're seeing
in the market right now um seven and a
half percent if you talk to the
geneticists and and those uh components
and especially now with the rules and
regs in place where we have a 30-day
window
um so once you harvest that if you are
sorry once you test that if it's less
than 0.3 and you get that additional 30
days of growth then you can spike up
above this seven and a half percent but
this is running on about a 25 to one
type ratio and i'm guessing uh several
of the geneticists uh prior to my talk
talked about that on some of the
assumptions there but if you look at the
bare ground model
it's not very profitable right now
the plastic culture model which is much
higher cost of production
is definitely not profitable now i will
say this is for my base scenario what i
will and you will find producers
throughout the country who have uh some
other uh contracts in place that may pay
higher than that they may have a higher
cbd percentage uh and may have a
different cost structure than what i'm
looking at so what i would tell you is
if you're getting into this and you want
to go look at it go to the university of
kentucky industrial hemp page and you
can find this budget and you can modify
it however you would like
to modify it to look at your individual
scenario that you have in there so
that's something you can you can
definitely go do
so kind of moving forward um when i
start to look at the fiber price and i
only pulled the fiber price in for the
nas survey because i wanted to point out
a couple different things so i'm really
trying to figure out what's going on in
north carolina pennsylvania on a few of
these other states while they have such
um
such a higher price
than what i would have expected i mean
even the 15 14 17 cents that you're
seeing down here is i think kind of on
the upper end of the spectrum
of what a lot of fiber processors are
going to be able to pay per pound uh to
to to make a profit especially right now
with the products and stuff that we're
kind of looking at and i'll touch on
that a minute and a little bit more here
in a minute one idea might be that
they're trying to dual or triple hard
triple crop this
so that may be where they're getting
this higher price but
that's definitely another red flag that
we need to think about
when we come back out with additional
surveys in this space so that we don't
get some some convoluted numbers like
this that are really really difficult to
explain
um and they don't match up to what we're
kind of seeing
from
some a group like pan x exchange who's
reporting this so
this this right here this gray line this
would be hemp this is fiber
material um i will tell you this is an
extremely thin market
uh to get pricing information from so
keep in mind that that is a bit uh of a
struggle but they've been right around
that 10 cents a lot
eight nine cents maybe up to 11 cents a
pound and that's going to be over here
on this uh
this axis over here uh what will also be
on this axis is this right here which is
the conventional grain side of things
it's been pretty flat it's been going up
in price
and i expect to continue to see this
kind of have an upward trend in price
potentially
especially if it's going to compete with
our traditional commodities and buy
acres away from those traditional
commodities because for the industry to
grow it's going to have to find products
and in markets that produce a profit
high enough for those producers to
switch acres out of those traditional
commodities into uh hemp production
so that's that's definitely something to
think about um this brighter blue line
is going to be over here on your right
hand side access and this is going to be
organic grain uh specifically so it's
got a little bit higher pricing
component which you would have ex which
you would expect um but we're still
seeing a lot of struggles in the grain
space to really get production in place
but i think this is something that's
going to come in time i mean we're still
trying to take a lot of canadian
genetics and genetics at northern
latitudes and bring those down
to to an area where we can grow grain as
uh
where we're trying to grow grain and we
don't have any chemicals or anything
like that in place yet either so
but that's a double-edged sword right
because
um many chemical companies many or for
your traditional companies are not going
to get into this game uh until they have
a minimum number of acres and we already
saw that we're pretty small fish on a
very big pond so
them committing r d
to chemicals for hemp specifically is
going to take some time yet still to get
to that point but i am really excited
about what zach and them are doing
at ars and collecting the genetics and
the genetic material and i'm really
looking forward to seeing how that
continues to develop
and help to bring cost of production
down and increase the yields
to make this crop more competitive
with the other commodities on the market
when i start to think about this from a
grain and fiber standpoint and i think
the industry's really you know starting
to reset itself and green and fiber are
starting to find a little bit of
traction
uh in the market you know i think i'm
probably still a little high here this
is not uh a level that you would see
um
in some states now there are some states
in the northern part of the u.s that are
seeing this 1200 pounds um
pricing's probably still a little low
but i am starting to see some positivity
on the green and on on the green and
fiber side
and i think there's going to be a lot of
potential in this space uh to to think
about how we get
these numbers to go even higher and i
think to get these numbers higher and
we'll talk a little bit about market
potential going forward
a little bit later but
you know trying to push up the yield
numbers and also trying to push up the
price numbers as we we seek markets that
have
high value
so when i think of high value products
especially in the fiber space i in
general i'm not speaking or thinking
about the textile industry i'm thinking
about
activate carbons i'm thinking about
bioplastics i'm thinking about those
types of products potentially
biofuels
depend upon how you're doing that and
which type of fuel you're going after
so i'm trying to think about how we get
to a higher price as well as we get
these yields up um
you know going forward for this side of
the coin
i will say on the production side
there's a whole lot more things coming
and i'll foreshadow a couple different
things that we're really working on here
at the university of kentucky and these
are projects that are about ready to
have
some manuscripts released um and
hit more of the mainstream but
i've been doing a lot of work with
looking at processors labs where they're
at in relation to where the hemp acres
are at and starting to think about how
we coordinate uh those two you know
specifically on the uh
the the floral side you're definitely
probably going to see a lot of
production close to these labs and stuff
because of the cost or sorry you would
see that on the grain and fiber side
because those products are very
difficult to move uh long distances so
you know you would think about want to
have a processor and have those
those acres pretty close to that
the labs we're still trying to figure
out if there's enough lab capacity to
handle this
in a timely fashion
to be able to make this market go
forward we've also put together a set of
hemp production contract checklists so
those of you who are thinking about
putting together a contract or those
producers who are thinking about
entering into a contract we we were
about ready to release our contract
checklist
and that's a project with the university
of maryland
that we're working on so
you know that's that's definitely
something that um
is coming along fairly well
and should give people a really good
insight into what they need to make sure
to have
in that contract
another piece that we're working on with
colorado state is really looking at the
market channels and
factors that affect the market channel
so when we start looking at
these
producers across the country how many
different market channels are they going
into them what what what is their
preferred market channel what do the
different market channels do to their
cost structure you know where how what
type of expertise do they have need to
have
to get into those marketplaces so
this is a really cool piece that we're
about ready to release as well we've
done it's a small survey right now it's
of about 30 producers in the state of
kentucky and and also in the state of um
colorado so granted it is a small sample
but it really gives a nice insight into
the number of different marketing
channels that some of these producers
are using and some of these producers
are using upwards of six and seven
different marketing channels so can you
imagine the the time it takes to manage
that that many different market channels
uh for for that producer so
uh that's a that's a really interesting
piece
so i'm gonna i'm gonna jump forward and
now you know the other hat i get to wear
now is on the consumption side
and i would say that the first thing
that that you know
we really run into that
i see is a big hurdle for the industry
to get over
is really what how do people associate
this crop so when we start to ask this
is out of a survey
that we've been running since february
of 2021 that runs monthly if you'd love
if you'd like to talk to us more about
that i'd love to
to have some further discussions with
people about what we have in this survey
but a lot of this survey has to deal
with
what what are the first things that come
to mind when you start to think about
hemp and cbd and what you're going to
see is marijuana weed
are two of the first ones cannabis
another big one that all come to the
forefront well that that really makes me
think about from a from an economic
standpoint
are we going to be able to get a segment
of the population that that doesn't want
to deal with
marijuana or anything associated with
marijuana are we ever going to get them
to be consumers of these hemp products
and also it tells me that we as a hemp
industry have not
told our story well enough or educated
consumers well enough to know the
difference between hemp and marijuana
and if we're truly going to get this
hemp industry to move forward we've got
to be able to differentiate the two and
understand the differences and
communicate those differences
between the two different crops
going forward if if this industry is
truly going to develop um and and meet
its true potential of what of the to
meet the potential that i think it
probably has the ability to do
um
this is some exciting news that i'm
seeing coming out of this survey so
we're looking at non-consumers and
likely to try cbd in the next month you
know so for 2021 you pulled august
september and october you know there's a
lot of those nine consumers this is a
sample of about a thousand national it's
a national sample national
representative sample uh and about 46 of
those non-consumers are saying that
they're willing to try or going to try
cbd in the next month so that tells me
that there's still a lot of interest
out there in this crop and interesting
consuming these products i will say that
this survey is probably right now really
driven more at the cbd side uh we are
getting into some of the other
components like we've got some stuff
coming up on uh infused beverages pet
foods and a few other
a few other ideas as well
that are percolating
around this survey
what i will tell you if you're
considering getting into this as a
processor or a manufacturer some of the
things that consumers are really
thinking about
um
is price is really important amount of
cbd in that dosage is really important
those tend to be the two big ones the
other big one is or cbd per serving you
know so those are the things that
they're really worried about medical
recommendation not as much but i think
you know depending upon what fda does in
the direction that they go
we'll also drive
a lot of this information once we once
we get back the human trial results uh
that are out there to to start to think
about
one other place that we're that we're
really working on with the university of
vermont and also colorado state when we
start to look at the hemp grain side of
things um you know we're doing a lot of
surveys on one side to to ask people
what they want what they like what they
think they want to consume but now we're
trying to validate that on the other
side and look at the scanner data and
what types of trends are we seeing in
this the actual sales food side of
things so this next couple of slides
really digs down more a little bit more
into the grain side of the coin
and really grain as an ingredient in
hemp food
so this is uh scanner data as i
mentioned granted it only goes up to
2019 we've just got 2020 data
but we have not gotten it added uh yet
to this chart
but what you see is in 17 that kind of
peaked and it's it's been trending down
a little bit um
i think that the 2020 data will probably
start to trend back up at least from the
early numbers that i've kind of seen i
don't know how much yet because we
haven't got that graphic uh completely
pulled back together but um and this is
total uh sales for him hemp ingredients
in supermarkets over time so just to
kind of give you a to set the baseline
on that
if you wanted to break that out by
region
interestingly enough up in the northeast
that new york pennsylvania area is is
really
been a big chunk of the sales for 2019
all along the coast
which i would have expected
the north
east north central is is also a fairly
big area um
still got some issues in the south and
the southeast uh east south central uh
to really get uh some additional sales
uh in that space at least
as we look at this for 2019
so but
as i mentioned this is only on the green
side of things uh we have not been able
yet to really pull much in on the cbd
side of things some of the new data for
2020 has a few more cbd products in it
that we'll be able to break out
specifically for it as well
if you wanted to look at this from
from another standpoint this right here
so i talked about infused beverages
that right now is really the the area
that's growing the most and the quickest
um is in these beverage spaces uh and
it's been a pretty hot topic that we're
trying to dig more into uh into what
type of beverages they're really looking
at and what types of ingredients are
going into those beverages
now keep in mind you've got some you got
some hurdles to get over here
from you can't really put cbd in food
unless you're in certain states um
so most of this right now should be in
hemp grain
but what does that look like and what
types of beverages is those going in
we've seen a pretty big drop in the
general foods but part of this is also
they've been in the process of
reorganizing some of the the upc codes
and some of this and the descriptions on
where they fall at in the grocery store
so
we're trying to sort through some of
those issues as well
um
and you know we're starting to see a big
uptick on the liquor side as well so
it's been it's been interesting to look
at this data um
as i mentioned we're getting deeper and
deeper into this research uh we'll have
something out later this summer
that really digs more into this and
provides a more national market
scope
for what what was going on in this
market
we're also doing some surveys on the
back side too trying to look at
who all seeking information on hemp
products um so the nice part is is that
um
you know 39 percent of our survey
have at least
seen have heard or seen information on
hemp products but they really don't pay
much attention you know so we've got it
we've got it they've heard of it now we
got to move them from
from from this point over to this point
where they pay attention it catches
their eye and then
um
hopefully into this seat more
information on so they have a deeper
understanding of what these products are
and what they what they bring to the
table
got more information on uh
you know on attitudes towards hemp
production and acidosis mentioned that
this is a study out of the
university of vermont one of our grad
students at the university of vermont
has been working on this for for part of
her dissertation
and we've been looking at pet foods
so their neutron attitudes towards hemp
and pet foods
you know a portion of them are also
positive to highly positive on that
we've started to see some states
institute
policies that allow
these types of products into those
market channels which is interesting uh
given that it's still illegal at the
federal level but we are starting to see
states move that direction and that
you're starting to see some of that show
up uh in this data as well construction
materials is another one um that people
are really positive on for this industry
plastics you know and i think these are
kind of two low-hanging fruits probably
the construction industry first uh
especially from the fiber side
which also has can get into some of the
carbon side of this of the coin as well
so it's got some interesting components
there that feed back into the production
uh space but we could delve deeper into
those if somebody wanted to
um
we still see quite a bit of people out
there thinking about the clothing and
textiles but
you know their attitudes aren't quite as
positive on it as they are some of the
other products that are out there so
um you know
just uh
something to keep in mind
as you go forward and as this industry
moves
forward so kind of looking forward um
you know from the policy standpoint i'm
really looking forward to the 2023 farm
bill and what changes we're going to
make in that and how we're going to move
this industry forward uh the types of
regulations you know there's a there's a
plan out there for an exemption for uh
grain and fiber production uh that's an
interesting uh
piece that's been put out there uh even
if those crops go hot given that they're
growing it for grain or fiber
they would be exempt from having to do
those testing components
trade is another uh interesting piece
especially if we move to the one percent
uh if you move to one percent i would
say that on the downside you know you've
restricted market access for a lot of
producers because if you go from point
three percent to one percent you don't
need nearly as many uh producers
especially on the floral side uh of the
coin as you do at the point three
percent so something to think about from
from that space the trade side of the
coin if we go to one percent there may
be some countries that now won't trade
with us as they have a zero percent thc
rule so how do we get around that can we
actually play in that space and will
will countries actually talk to us
with with a one percent rule um i think
some will i think some won't um so
that's that's been a big issue uh
investment public and private so we've
seen a lot of private investment
especially in the fiber side of the coin
and in the green side of the coin
going in but it's got
you know this crop was out of production
for 80 years
and really hasn't had any uh very little
research done on it so
it's taking a lot of effort
on the private side to get that done but
as many of you probably saw within the
last week
nifa put out
its piece on the public funding that
it's been providing for the hemp
industry and i was proud to say that
several of our projects that i'm on
were in that publication
and i think there's more public funding
to to come on that front
from a production standpoint i think i
will see an uptick in grain and fiber
acres commodity prices are going to
continue to be a problem to compete with
those other commodities biomass supply
has dropped
from those over supply days
but
there's still quite a bit left out there
on the market that we still haven't
completely worked through so i think
we'll see floral production acres flat
to down a little bit again for this year
but this will also be very location
dependent uh as there are some locations
around the country specifically maybe up
in the northeast
uh that um
i'm starting to hear grumblings or
rumblings of uh those prices being
fairly strong for the 2020 or 2022 uh
production period
on the consumer side i think we have a
lot of market confusion that we've
really got to work through if we're
going to to educate these consumers and
bring them on board
as hemp producers labeling regulations
such as grass are also going to be
important and can we get those done
because consumers we know consumers care
about what they put in their body so are
we gonna are we gonna have the right
labeling and what type of regulations
are we gonna have in place for that
need to understand non-consumers so why
are these people non-consumers and why
what would switch them to the other side
of the coin uh from the processing side
and manufacture side consumers are
paying a lot of attention and you have
but you're gonna have to catch their
attention so what was really nice early
on in this industry is we got a lot of
free advertising so as this industry was
really growing into 2019 um you know
they were talking about this being a
golden ticket and and being the the crop
that's going to solve everything well
that's no longer the case today and now
the media will talk about this this crop
is uh you know
it's bubbles burst and it's done but
it's not done uh so we're going to have
to figure out how uh to advertise and
and
and communicate the benefits of this
crop
going forward
so
this is my contact information please
feel free to reach out to me um about
any of these topics or any other
hemp topics you would like to talk about
i did stick over here on the right hand
side because all this work
that you're seeing and any and even more
behind the scenes uh would not be
possible uh without the funding agencies
that are funding a lot of this research
uh to move this uh to help move this
industry forward
so i'm going to stop there um
and
let's let's answer some questions if
they're already
[Music]
awesome talk tyler um yeah so we have a
bunch of questions in the chat
um one person asks uh why did the price
in oregon fall to zero in september 2020
yeah so and um
for that uh the price in oregon i think
fell to zero in that year because of the
the fire wildfires that they had out
there that year so there was almost no
crop if i remember correctly uh
from that so they they didn't report out
of price that year
great um
another question asked what percentage
of states have formed commodity
commissions for hemp do most have
checkoffs
um
so there have been a lot of states that
have formed um
all these little commissions and uh
groups i think that's one thing that
we're you know we're seeing with a very
young infant industry is a lot of those
commodity groups have not congealed and
kind of come together and had one voice
yet so i think as this industry
continues to develop we'll start to see
um
we'll start to see that piece come
together and help strengthen this
industry
to that point now in terms of um
how you asked about uh
checkoff programs right now
to my knowledge there is no check off
program uh they've been trying to pursue
a check off program but to my knowledge
it hasn't been completely set up yet
um
this question um
asks is there enough demand for seed and
fiber to grow this industry
well you know that's that's
that's a great question and and i think
there is enough demand um i think it's
just taking a whole lot of
infrastructure to get that demand up and
running so i mean i i think there is um
you know there are a lot of people who
want to consume this grain but they they
really haven't gotten to the point of
being able to consume it because it's a
fairly high
high cost um
uh superfood i guess if you want to call
it a superfood food
you know it's a fairly high cost piece
on that side in terms of the fiber side
it's still fairly highly called
it's still pretty costly
so we got to get production up
to bring those cost of production down
but it's also a chicken and egg too
because most producers aren't going to
move forward with production until they
have
a place to go with that so it's been
it's been a struggle but i think we're
starting to see more and more companies
um and investments being made to that
awesome um
other question asks do you have storage
cost data for raw flowers over 12 months
or extracted cbd over the same time
frame uh that that's data right now we
don't have it is part of our um
production cost survey that we have put
together however we you know as i kind
of mentioned that's still stuck in omb
and we haven't been able to send that
out so
but that's something we're really trying
to get a handle on is what is that
storage cost over 12 months in addition
beyond that when you start to store it
over 12 months what
is the degradation of those
cbd and other compounds that are in that
and is there degradation and what is the
best storage method to look at that so
we've done some really brief studies at
the university of kentucky
to look at different storage methods
one storage method would be just to
store it in a super sack
uh in a raw floral material at the
proper moisture level we've done some
freeze drying of it you know freeze
drying is really nice but it's also
really expensive um so
you know we're we're kind of still
looking at
that
great um
a question asks does canada have
registered pesticides for itself
yes they do but they're they're also
have been grain producers for 30 plus
years uh so they have a lot longer
history in that space and they do have
chemicals approved up there and within
the us i guess i should be a little more
clear on that we do have some chemicals
approved but they're all biological
chemicals so
um so they're they're fit more into that
organic production space uh probably
than many others
great another question asks are there
any market distinctions recognizing
short and or long hemp fiber
um
so
so i think depending upon the industry
you're trying to go into i think that's
one of the things that we really need to
take into consideration
so for example if you were going into a
process of flooring uh hemp flooring
that's going to use the whole plant well
they don't really care about what if
it's long or short strand fibers because
it's all going into one piece now you
get into the textile space you get into
some of the other
end products yes they care about that
length and i think that's been one of
the things that the fiber industry has
really struggled with
is when we originally rolled a lot of
this out we just uh we put fiber seed
out in the field and said we'll produce
it and and it was kind of this field of
dreams and um the the industry will come
well
we can't really think about it in that
way we have to start with the end
product where's where's it going is it
going into bioplastics is it going into
the automobile manufacturing industry is
it going into
fiber and start to think and work back
down the supply chain or up the supply
chain
to the producer to get the right
genetics and stuff in place to produce
that type of
fiber so we're starting to see more
along that lines uh moving forward but
uh it's been a struggle to get there
great um another question from ernie
sieber at alabama a m asks
what's the projected economics of the
growing medical cannabis industry as
more states are legalizing the process
well i i can't say i've done a whole lot
of work uh in the medical cannabis side
of things but what what i can say is
that we had a medical cannabis bill
introduced in the state of kentucky
um and from the rough estimates that
you know we were doing on that i mean
from a production standpoint i think it
was going to take like 14 15 acres
to produce enough cannabis for the
medical side depending upon what the
assumptions were on the number of
consumers
to satisfy the state of kentucky's need
um
so
from that standpoint it's not a whole
lot of acres now you can juxtapose that
to the tax side of the coin uh and yes
there would be a lot of taxes on that
side now we did not get into estimating
what those taxes are
and how much that would benefit the
state but
you know as we can see from states like
colorado california those tax benefits
can can be
significant
great uh interesting question do you see
hemp fiber processing as being a high
value uh
to various industries due to its ability
to produce commodities across the board
and what percentage of fiber processors
do we have across the us to handle this
volume
well a lot of the fiber processors
across the country are very small at
this point top so that that is one of
the issues um now the question becomes
is what type of fiber processing do we
want to do i mean there are processes
out there that we can chemically reddit
there are processes out there that don't
require uh necessarily decortication to
happen or it can decortication can be
done in a different method
so
you know
but keep in mind that the coordination
process is really there to break it into
the herd the best uh
primarily hurting the bass side of
things so you know if you
if you really want to think about it
from a textile standpoint you're really
in the bass game but unfortunately as a
as a decorator uh in terms of volume for
that to coordicate you're really in the
herd side of things so you've got to
find markets for both heard and bass
specifically heard uh to think about how
you uh become profitable in that space
so um but most those fiber processors
right now on a fairly small scale i mean
i've heard of some processors there are
some processors starting uh this year in
2022 that are larger and i think will
grow in scale but
commercial scale
they'll be commercial scale but on the
small side of commercial scale so it's
it's still we're still several years out
there
a couple questions regarding the 2023
farm bill
um i guess this
makes farmers become licensed with their
individual states if they're already
sending data to fsa
um do you think that this
is good for the hemp industry do you
think it needs to be lobbied um to be
removed like what are your thoughts on
that
um
you know that that's not really
something that um
you know i get into analyzing the
policies that are made not really
setting the policy um so that's that's
been one of those really interesting
pieces now to go along with that though
um
you know
it depends upon how the regulatory
framework is set up i mean you know
there's a couple of other questions in
here about uh legalization of the
medical of marijuana
and how it affects the industry if if
marijuana is legalized across the
country it probably changes the whole
paradigm of how this crop is managed
um from a regulatory standpoint so that
that is one of those pieces to to think
about and watch now i will say that the
marijuana industry and the hemp industry
right now are almost in direct
competition when you think about delta
eight uh and some of the other pro well
specifically delta eight um
and i think that's something that
industry really needs to think about uh
is how you deal with that um going
forward because
if we are under the same tax regulations
as the as the marijuana industry i think
it becomes a real struggle uh for this
industry to be profitable so but at the
same time i understand why processors
have done it because that's how they
they survived the downturn uh in the
pricing since 24 2019
but i guess to try and get that back do
i think um
you should have to be licensed with both
it's a bit of a burden right now and i
would agree that is a burden
but i think the other piece of that too
is
just because the data the only data
that's going to fsa
is
um
planted and harvested acres
so they're not doing anything with the
regulatory component
of is it hemp or is it marijuana so
they're not doing anything on the
testing side until that testing
requirement gets rid we get rid of that
then i think you're you're gonna have to
report to the state or you're going to
have to report to the federal
government through the usda hemp program
one of the two on that and you know
until they change that
awesome thank you uh another question
um asks the major variation on planted
versus harvested acres in colorado in
one of your slides uh is there an
explanation or is that an indication of
an alternate underground market
so no it's not necessarily an
underground market if you were to look
at kentucky it's it's the same issue
there too so
take for example uh in the state of
kentucky you have to have a license to
hold the raw materials so if you've been
holding that material since 2019 you
still have a license and you still have
a uh
a planted you know a number that's
planted or licensed
but you may not have harvested it so and
you're also seeing a lot of failures
that take place uh in these so one it
never you know you planted it but it
failed to to come out of the ground
where it failed you had lots of weed
pressure so you bush hogged it down so
you start to see a lot of discrepancies
in there as well and if you were to look
at kentucky numbers you see a lot of
discrepancies between planted and
harvested uh in general so i think
that's a common trend you see across the
country but that is something to think
about um
you know is there's a there's a licensed
acres there's a planted acres and there
are harvested acres and those vary quite
differently from one state to the next
great
another question asks uh where are you
seeing private and public cooperation or
collaboration in developing supply
chains specific to various market
channels
um
ask that question one more time
um where i guess like what states are
you seeing or where are you seeing in
the country private and public
cooperation or collaboration in
developing supply chains that are
specific to
specific markets so i will tell you one
of the really cool well
colorado is probably
out in front of a lot of states they
have what they call the champ report
which was a very large effort
on the part of colorado state university
and the colorado department of ag to
bring all the constituents and
stakeholders from across the state on
all levels of the supply chain together
and try and put together a comprehensive
plan for the development of hemp in that
state and you can go out and find the
champ report
online for that state uh that's probably
a state that uh
is moving forward on that side of things
uh new york is another example with
their food science lab there at uh in
geneva
and some of the things that they have
going on on that side of the coin
so i mean there's lots of examples out
there uh
you know especially in some of those
early states
questions asks any forward uses being
utilized for alternative products for
fiber on the west coast such as trash
bags and paper that can be utilized in
the southeast region to create a need
for hemp acreage
so
um yeah there there are a lot of things
so we were just uh out at noco and there
was a lot of uh
uh hemp being put into plastic bags um
into those not necessarily pencils but
they're they're trying to get into some
of those consumables
that that i think could generate some
additional acres in the southeast i
think in the southeast though we're
still struggling with the right genetics
uh to to get at those lower latitudes um
or to get at the the latitudes in the
southeast part of the us to to really
grow
um
high quality fiber that's going to go
into some of those so
yeah i mean it's coming along but it's
kind of slow
i wanted to jump in with a question that
i addressed in the chat but i thought it
would be this would be something uh our
lab could speak to a little bit and i'd
love to hear mark's
opinion of as well so dave asks
are you aware of any efforts to
establish fiber standards grading
testing protocols either in regional
markets private standards or among state
or federal entities
i'm thinking along the lines of usda
cotton and wool program so i love that
question and that's
very near and dear to our heart
at our laboratory so we are
developing a set of phenotypic
standards for hemp fiber quality right
now in conjunction with chris dell home
at the southern regional research center
in new orleans
we've developed
a usda hemp phenotyping handbook where
we measure everything from
fiber oil
plant morphology secondary metabolites
including cannabinoids and develop
rigorous ways of measuring those so
developing standards for hemp is
interesting
and you mentioned
cotton and wool programs
one
similar analog that could be leveraged
to help address this question is looking
at a lot of the work done with flax flax
is also a bass fiber
there's machinery
that can evaluate
flax fiber quality
can that be applied to hemp well that's
an ongoing project we've got going on
with chris delholm
in new orleans uh interestingly there
there are hemp fiber phenotyping
machinery um those were made in the ussr
pre-fall of of the soviet union so those
machineries that machinery is not really
available nowadays um
to the best of my knowledge but
i tyler is probably gonna have a lot of
thoughts on the economics of uh fiber
standards so
zach i i'm glad to hear that you all are
working on that because i think that's
one of the big issues um that we're
really facing uh within the industry
because i think we're we're missing the
boat on how we're pricing this stuff so
if you want to talk about the biomass
segment we're pricing it on a percent
cbd well cbd is not the only valuable
component in that
another industry that you might think
about that has something kind of similar
to that that might be able to be used to
be the sugar industry basically when
they bring it in they base it on the
theoretical
uh sugar extract
uh of that so that would be another
industry to think about that that kind
of does some of that uh on the
and i think we're doing the missing the
boat on the green and fiber side as well
so on the fiber side the quality
component and i think that really is
going to be driven by what those end
uses for that are
uh and we really need to rethink that
pricing model uh that sits there on the
grain side you know unfortunately in the
u.s or fortunately in the u.s however
you want to put it
you know soybeans are are sold on a per
bushel basis not on the oil content you
go to south america oil content matters
and for this product oil content should
matter um because it's pretty high in
omega six and three um you know so it's
got some other
health implications that could also be
in there that that are something to
consider as well so um i would be really
interested zach to talk with you some
more about how that that's working
because this is also
some of this pricing stuff is also part
of an ars project
awesome and with that i believe we hit
the three o'clock mark uh thank you
everyone for joining uh thank you dr
mark for
giving that talk
um
yeah thank you for all your support
throughout this webinar series we're
extremely grateful for it um and it's
nice to see people from all all
different walks of life
coming together to learn about him
hey and
not to take the last word but i just
want to echo that this has been so much
fun i've learned so much and i i really
appreciate all of the time you all have
spent here with us so
go grow some hemp make some money do
some awesome research
thanks again everyone
thank you all
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu